hey guys so this is my favorite
youtubers have been doing this life and
letters tag and I thought give it a shot
why not
it would have stand for animals as a
socially introverted child with lots of
pets around the house I found it easier
to empathize with animals than people so
I'm involved lots of animal charities
I'm a big advocate of animals rights B
would have to be books I'm a massive
bibliophile and I read from a very early
age my favorite books probably brave new
world by Aldous Huxley
although the Fallen Our Stars by John
Green His Dark Materials by Philip
Pullman and my family other animals by
Gerald dole pretty close I actually got
my copy of Northern Lights signed by
Philip Pullman in that empty seat would
be cinema when I was a kid I dreamt of
becoming either an actor or a director
and I absolutely loved them my favorite
directors would be Stanley Kubrick
Steven Spielberg Ridley Scott and
recently Guillermo del Toro my favorite
film is probably 2001 a Space Odyssey d
is debating when I was in school I got
into the sixth film debating society
when I was actually near 9 because the
name is teacher brought me long thought
I'd be good at it turns out I was I
ended up captaining the team in my last
year and I won several awards at
International Model United Nations
conferences II would be environment the
thing which I'm passionate about more
than anything else in the world is
raising awareness for environmental
concerns in particular global warming
atmosphere excises that's sort of where
my heart lies but also species
preservation there's a famous quote from
Jared Allah's saying that whenever you
touch a spider's web you send
tremors shimmering throughout the whole
web and that's exactly what happens with
the ecosystem except we're not touching
a spider's web were ripping great holes
in it f would be friends I'm a kind of
person who gets on very well with pretty
much anybody but I only make a small
number of really close friends G games
pretty big game here my favorites would
probably be Sid 4 on the PC
timesplitters 3 on the Gamecube and
Legend of Zelda Twilight Princess on the
Wii and the original XCOM the 1994
version H would be Henry Henry was my
childhood pet we had got him as a kitten
when I was about four years of three or
four years old and he stayed in the
family until he died a few years ago
when I just finished my third year of
university as I said before a very
introverted kid and he was one of my
very very closest friends
I improvement I have to challenge myself
to improve I will always go into a
situation and try and come out of it
better than I was before
I'm kind of competitive with myself and
I'm always seeking to do better I have
to do better
J is for John now I have as I said
before a small number of very close
friends but John is my best friend and
has been for many many years he's kind
of like the brother I never had
Kate would be for katechon which is the
town in which I currently live and have
lived for about the past ten years el
levity I'm often the person who tries to
brighten the mood when things get
serious
I do take life seriously it's just that
I there's no reason why you can't be
serious about something and have fun
whilst you're doing it em music I'm sure
this is probably the thing which most
people say in their life and letters tag
but I really love the idea that music is
something that's eternal it doesn't
matter what century you live in or where
you come from or how old you are
music elicits the same emotional
response in everyone I play saxophone
and I have sung in the past I'm also
teaching myself to play the piano and in
the future I'm looking to play the
guitar favorite classical composers
would be buck Handel and Copeland while
my favorite contemporary poses would be
handsome and Howard Shore and would be
for negativity one of my biggest flaws
as a person is that I am relentlessly
negative about myself it's connected to
striving to improve but I am almost
always far too harsh on myself and this
has got the better of me the past and
it's something which I'm really working
to improve on oh would be Oxford it's
the University where I did my
undergraduate degree and has formed a
really big part of making Who I am today
I think P has to be for physics there
was not really anything else that I
could say for it generally I just had
this fascination with how things work i
when I was a kid I used to love taking
things apart and seeing how the smaller
parts interacted to make the larger
thing and that's something which I just
like doing all scales so from the
subatomic scale things like quantum
field theory the path integral
formulation in quantum field through
particulate it's fascinating as is the
relativistic formulation of
electrodynamics
q would be quizzes I love being asked
questions and I'm a hoarder of knowledge
I love finding out things and little
nuggets and information are would be
Ross Bob Ross to be particular kind of
shoehorn this one in he was an American
painter who did a series of paintings
shows called the joy of painting and he
has this most amazing gentle philosophy
on life s would be Scouts I was part of
the scouts with him for about ten years
from Cubs right the way through to
Explorer scouts and much as an extremely
uncool image which I suppose I do too
I loved it I loved my time in scouts I
made some of my absolute best friends in
that time t would have to be teaching
the act of teaching is something which I
enjoy tremendously and I think partly
why I got into teaching in the first
place and communication and
communication of information is
something which I find in harity
fascinating and also extremely enjoyable
to see the little spark off in someone's
eye when they finally understand
something is one of the best feelings in
the world you would be for ungrateful
it's the one thing which I am scared of
being I think more than anything else v
would be vlogging it's almost a
continuation of the old tradition and
like from an anthropological perspective
I think it's extremely interesting but
as a foreigner in his own right and the
lack of distance between content creator
and consumer is something which I am
really excited to be part of and I'm
really excited to see how it evolves in
the future w would be words I find
etymologies really interesting in the
connections between words that are
seemingly completely separate whether
they're in different languages sometimes
even the opposite of one another and
they have the same root I find language
tying into communication really
interesting and with that in mind
x is for xanthophyll eeeh which is like
in the color yellow because I do so fun
color y ug it kind of had to be really
YouTube is my favorite site in the
internet it's the Tatooine of my my
online universe I just I love the
diversity of the site my favorite
YouTube channels will probably be the OS
cast Network crash course charlie is so
cool like Alex de Nicola and Ed plant
lastly Zed would be for Zim Jon Kabat
specifically there really helps you on
some of these in no way Jon kabat-zinn
is an American professor of medicine
who's deeply involved in the connection
between Western medicine and Eastern
meditative practices specifically he is
connected with the school of meditation
called mindfulness meditation it's not a
religious form of meditation it's
completely secular and it's something
which I've been doing now for a little
while okay that's it we run out letters
in the Roman alphabet I hope you found
this interesting leave a like if you did
and if you'd like to do this video
yourself please
I know we can't do video responses any
more if you want to do your own version
of The Life and Letters tag then please
make a video and send it to me on
Twitter I am at slamming ox fizz and
I've really interested to see what my
subscribers come up with